[Music]  as an idea  letter dinu set up my show this is it we  do your monologue right there and I  stand right here  oh yeah well anyway folks we got a great  show tonight and ya know if you heard  about what Obama's Justin you're you're  standing back there like this if he's  behind me to the right just during the  monologue while I'm trying to do it Jeff  it's like he's back to me like I don't  feel like the latest Obama of course is  on the cover of Newsweek and he's also  on the cover of The New Yorker magazine  and a lot of people are speculating that  he's the first gay president and I was  trying to just like okay what stop  having fun and making funny stuff and  get back  [Music]